and the door without the brain
see that human guide has gone insane to
the point where I don't know if I'll
upset the status quo if I drove poison
in the water main
listen close to everybody's heart and
hear that breaking sound hopes and
dreams are shattering apart and crashing
to the ground I cannot believe my eyes
of the world's filled with filth and
lies
it seems to me
evil inside of me is on the run
just when you've almost drown you find
yourself and song
there's good in everybody's heart keep
it safe and sound with morph you can do
your part to turn
I cannot believe my
the one finally growing wise it seems to
me some kind of harmony is on
don't see the whole world howling in
pain the darkish everywhere and panty
shots don't seem to care that seeing a
dark Annie's all that will remain
oh listen close to everybody's heart and
hear that breaking sound hopes and
dreams are shattering apart and crashing
to the ground I cannot believe my
a the world feel we build then lies
because it seems to me
all inside Ernie is on the rise
we were gonna have the orange in it but
it didn't make it cuz we had to do at 27
possibly 28 times before we got it and
we thought the orange would have added
an extra level simplicity the orange is
not easy to play I cannot believe my
eyes the world feel of growing wise yet
filled with growing lies as well and
wolves and wives what darkness and
easily thank you for doing that with me
it was it was it worked
time for outtakes reap Lost and Found is
when you feel you've all
I cannot believe my eyes
are my ears
sorry Jesus girl one-chord she devours
you one gourd
shake that orange baby shake that orange
shake get it it's a little too close to
my face right now